all right
first it was President gota by rajapaksa
now protesters want his replacement gone
outside the country's Central Railway
Station they demonstrated calling for
acting president ranel Vikram singha to
resign why does he plan to come nothing
else he want to save the rajapakshas he
want to safeguard
the street he wants to he wants to
safeguard the rajapaksha's uh
briberies and also Corruptions and
that's why
Vikram singhav has voted out of
parliament at the last general elections
he returned as an MP with a single seat
allocated to his party
on Wednesday Parliament will choose a
successor to go to biraj paksa the
rajapaksa party the slpp has said it
will back Vikram singer they have 120
seats they will try to bring
rajapak's Avatar go rajabang says ghost
will become president that's why we are
opposal don't don't try to bring granil
as a president it will be big the big
demonstration in the country after the
20th
such warnings prompted Vikram Singh had
to declare a state of emergency on
Sunday it gives police and the military
more power to detain and arrest
protesters
but that isn't deterring the
demonstrators
from April 9 to till now nearly uh three
or four times
the state of emergency has been declared
and curfews has been declared but people
came to this struggle people
came to the road and they are saying
slogans and they are protesting they are
they are never scared of this surprise
has largely ignored the criticism
do we fight each other and destroy the
country or do our parties work together
peacefully and rebuild this country that
is the most important political question
we face today
calls like this for them to remember
they represent the people not themselves
Miller Fernandez Al Jazeera Colombo
let's take a closer look at the four
presidential candidates so far Daniel
wikram a singer became the acting
president on Friday the former prime
minister is from the same party as
former president got to buy Roger paxa
and protest leaders have said people
will come out in force to demonstrate if
he's elected then there's opposition
leader sajith Prema dasam if elected
he's promising to fix the economy by
Reviving tourism boosting exports and
attracting more foreign investment
is a former Minister from the same party
as got a biomatopaxa he's relying on a
coalition of votes from within the
ruling slpv and opposition parties for
support
and finally Marxist party leader anura
Kamara de sanayaka he's promising to fix
the economic crisis within six months if
elected
you're a Seeker Jaya Cody is a political
analyst and a former editor of the Daily
News in Sri Lanka he says many people
don't support the acting president
reynoldsinger
there's a severe public backlash severe
strong public outcry against the
appointment of the acting president
running Vikram singer because the people
of the country see him as part of the
failed Administration which plunged Sri
Lanka into bankruptcy earlier this year
although Mr ranel Vikram singer took up
their position two months ago people see
him as a protector of the rajapaksha
family which is largely responsible for
the current Miss Sri Lanka is facing uh
in that context paper demand was coming
to step down along with gotaberade
Parliament to elect a president who has
the support of the public if not the
support at least the credibility of
person who commands The credibility of
the public so now instead of dealing
with this strong public outcry in a
meaningful manner Vikram singer has
imposed a state of emergency uh
allowing the security forces to take
severe action on protesters you have to
understand that the situation in Sri
Lanka today I mean on Monday has been
peaceful there are small protests across
the country against the prime minister's
appointment as the acting president but
aside from those peaceful protects there
hasn't been a single incidence of
incident of violence however the Prime
Minister has imposed a state of
emergency which is a Highly Questionable
move and many bodies including the Sri
Lanka Association the highest
professional body of lawyers in Sri
Lanka and so many Civil Society
organizations have criticized the move
describing it as a highly unwarranted
act at this point in time